hey guys i'm ella may make sure you
check me out on the bootleg capture
boulet cab show special guest
ella mae thank you for having me thank
you for coming i haven't seen you in
years it's been a while it has been i
think it's uh 20
you know what's crazy is i met you in
2017
before you even like i want to say
before you really had music out yeah i
think we were i want to say it was maybe
like one or two eps it was like very
pre-pre-boot up yeah
pre-pre-previewed up yeah i don't
remember who brought you up to the
station i might have been someone from
interscope and they were just like hey
we just want to introduce you to her
she's going to be the next thing and
like jesus
and then here you are making the r b
music i grew up loving oh thank you yes
um
it kind of took a while to make this
album yeah and you know what i love
about your album is like when i saw the
track list you know it's it's hard to
make an album with that many songs
and it'd be fire thank you but you made
us wait so i feel like you made us wait
right so it's like okay cool you made us
wait and you know you delivered so it
wasn't like super super intentional that
i made everyone wait i think everyone
thinks that i like disappeared off the
face of the earth and then like came
back it really was like
boot up trip my debut album end of 2018
and then for the whole of 2019 i toured
like literally january to january 2020 i
toured um and i can't i'm not really
like a record on the road like i need to
be stationary and like set so i wasn't
in the studio so 2020 was always the
year for me to record anyway
um it took a little bit longer than we
planned pandemic yeah and the pandemic
like i didn't i really didn't want to
put something out during the pandemic
and not be able to like work it properly
i feel like everyone kind of at first
the virtual stuff was cool but then
months in everyone was like i'm sick and
tired of seeing so tired yeah so i
wanted to make sure i would be able to
work it properly so yeah it took a
little bit long but we're here now yeah
100 um yeah you got some crazy records
on here uh fallen angel i want to say is
one of my favorites yes i love the outro
at the end yes um the roddy record is
crazy thank you um what would you say
like where did you kind of pull your
inspiration from for this project yeah i
think it was really just my life in real
time like i think with my debut album uh
the studio was really like still quite
new to me and i was like figuring out
what i wanted to sound like and what i
wanted to say
and this album i felt like i was super
confident in what i wanted to say and
what i wanted to sound like um and the
message that i wanted to get across and
really i was just going in and kind of
like diary entries almost and whatever i
felt on that day is what came out that's
what it felt like yeah did you go
through a breakup during the pandemic or
something i did yeah yeah so so that
there's all that all you need is a
breakup a good breakup to be fair my
album's not a sad album it's not but
there are some moments you know yeah
there's moments there's moments for sure
but i'm also learning that like life
happens in moments like happiness
happens a moment sadness happens in
moments success comes in moments and
like obviously those moments come back
they you know it's like a roller coaster
um but yeah there's moments of i think
more so moments of happiness but there's
definitely moments of of sadness on this
on the album yeah um
how old is the right like how how long
ago did you guys do the writing record
um
i want to say we did it last summer so
it's not that it's not that old yeah but
we're like fully fully finished at
probably top of the year
um
but roddy and i we we actually did
another song first um for was supposed
to be from us album um and then we kind
of came back around and we had this this
was one of the last records we did on my
album um but from the beginning the
start of uh
me recording i was like i really want
roddy on this album because i'm such a
big fan so yeah must have made it happen
yeah do you like are you conscientious
of like um
i said that you make the music i grew up
loving and i feel like for a while we
kind of were missing
r b like true r b in terms of like the
forefront of music like yeah but i do
feel like um
it's coming back
i agree um but i feel like you had a lot
to do with that are you conscientious of
that like because i feel like you kind
of filled something that was missing you
know yeah um thank you first of all
that's a big compliment um i don't feel
like i was super super super aware at
the time i think it's really just like
that's the music i grew up on too so
it's really just like my influences and
who i love and the music i love and
that's just the music that comes out
because that's just what i loved
listening to and what i love making i
don't think anyone could have ever
really planned what happened with boot
up or what happened with tripp i think
it was just like
clearly something that the industry was
missing and what people wanted um and i
definitely i definitely do feel like it
gave gave rmb a lot more like mainstream
attention at the time and then since
then it's r b's kind of been taken over
back yeah but it's still a pr it's still
a very hard genre if you're not like a
crossover it's still even though we're
making waves
somewhat it's still a really hard genre
to work and i think um as an r b artist
you just kind of have to be aware of
that and just try your best to um
to like navigate it's quite hard to
navigate through yeah like shout out um
money long she just went number one with
like a real traditional r b record
i'm like this [ __ ] is number one in two
formats and it's very very hard to do
very hard i don't think people
understand that yeah i used to do in
such like a pop um or like rap bass yeah
industry yeah 100 um talk about like how
did you spend your pandemic were you
here in the states were you back home in
the uk where were you at i was in the
states yeah i couldn't actually leave
because i was right before the pandemic
happened i was in the process of getting
my green card okay so
like while you're in the process you're
not supposed to leave because they can
deny you like re-entry right and then
obviously covert happened the pandemic
in the embassy shot so if i would have
left that you wouldn't come back i would
have got stuck at home yeah i know a few
people who that happened to yeah yeah
and i was in the middle of making an
album and i didn't want to i could make
it album at home yes but um your team's
out here right yeah everyone's here so
it was just like it would have been
really hard for me to do that so i was
here yeah i didn't go home
the first time i went home um was
november that just passed and that was
the first time in two years so yeah um
with buddha being such a massive record
how much did you pay attention to all
the remixes i made the tense i saw i saw
a lot of t-pain caught a [ __ ] body
killed it absolutely killed it but he
kills like i don't know why everybody
was acting so surprised i wasn't but i
was just like yes i feel like he doesn't
get enough credit at all like t payne is
actually a goat i don't think people
understand i agree i agree he's his
we would like to say he's him duncan yes
he is him he is like i feel like he
really created like a new lane when he
came out in his like in his prime there
was no one really really really doing
what t-pain was doing and he can
actually sing like i don't think people
and he performs his ass off you know
i've never seen him live he's one of my
favorite live performers i need to see
him live yeah like for the like his size
the way he'd be moving around and
popping and locking and i'm just like
jesus i've seen videos but i've never
actually experienced it in person yeah
um how like
when we talk about mustard i feel like
somehow we just talked about t-pain
doesn't get enough credit i feel like
muster doesn't get enough credit just
for him being the ceo that he is the guy
that he is and just like the prolific
i mean you know not a lot of people have
had runs like mustard um
how involved was he with this project i
feel like he was heavily involved in the
first project like how like are his
fingerprints all over the album yeah
he's still he's still he definitely i
think he was definitely more involved in
in the debut um but he still produced i
think i want to say six of the 15 on on
this album i think i think i'm correct
um and i always like i don't there's
nothing that i do that i don't play him
like his opinion is really really really
important to me um and he's never
steered me wrong so he's still super
super involved whether it's being like
you know the the label owner of 10
summers or whether it's production-wise
he's still super involved and he's not
like scared to tell me that he doesn't
like something and i'm not scared to
tell him i don't like something like
he's super just organic and natural so
he's very involved yeah did you feel
like uh there was a i feel like there
was in like that 2018 2019 range you
were on a lot of hooks you were kind of
like the go-to do you think so i didn't
feel like i just i'm thinking of the
meek album yeah um there was a i feel
like you were on a couple of hooks right
not really not really maybe i'm just
thinking of the me yeah i feel like for
a while there i just heard you on the
radio 24 7 no because you know what it
was it was really wild because boot up
happened and then trip happened which
was all over the radio and then my album
happened and then meek was like right
after my album 24 7. so the timing of it
i just felt like it was lma radio for
like six months it was like jesus i know
everyone was tired of it like we don't
want to hear this anymore um but yeah no
meek was really the
the main uh 24 7 was the main feature i
did i didn't really do i haven't really
done many features to be fair when it
comes to people because i'm sure people
hit you a lot to do a feature like you
know what people actually don't really
i feel like there's like a misconception
that people think like so many people
hit me not so much wow i don't surprise
you yeah they need to start hey
y'all got to tap in what's up y'all we
got to stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our good folks at
bluechew.comfellas
when it's time to get that [ __ ] going
you know what i'm saying when it's time
to hit the sack with a young lady you
need that confidence
trust me maybe you had a bad day maybe
your anxiety's through the roof you're
stressed well that could [ __ ] up
everything when it comes time for you to
get down you know what i'm saying with a
young lady or a young man whatever
you're into uh well young etc whatever
you like you know what i'm saying listen
bluetooth.com is to the rescue bluechu
is a unique online service it delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in a chewable form at a
fraction of the cost and it's fire it
works trust me bluetooth tablets they
help men achieve harder stronger [ __ ]
stronger erections
and it combats all forms of ed all right
that's right
if you're feeling a little uh like ah
man [ __ ] ain't been right down there
listen that blue chew come to the rescue
get your dick right bud all right trust
me when i say it hey listen blue chew
it's an online prescription service it's
the best part there's no weird awkward
visits awkward conversations at the
doctor's office none of that it ships
right to your door in a discreet package
all right it's super simple go to
bluetooth.com you can consult with one
of their medical providers uh and then
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and it's all
online all right that's right
and uh the best part is you can go to
bluechew.com right now use my promo code
bootleg at checkout that's use the promo
code bootleg at checkout and you're
gonna get your first month of blue chew
for free
just five dollars shipping trust me when
i say
this [ __ ] is lit all right i love blue
chew
maybe you're married
maybe you um
just going through it at work and you
just feel like you need that extra
little boost that extra confidence man
edie hits a lot of men in different ways
you know what i'm saying that blue chew
will have your dick right my g
bowman
bowman
thor's hammer bluechu.com
get your first month for free with the
promo code bootleg asap go do that um
what what is like the music that you're
currently listening to that's like
inspiring you that like you know you're
just a fan of yeah oh that's a great
question um i was just talking about
blast project the other day shout out to
blast i i'm such a fan yeah his melodies
are so cool and he killed the kendrick
album yes yes he did yes kendrick's
album i haven't listened to it in its
entirety yet so you haven't sat with the
whole project yet no yeah i feel like i
need to be in a certain like headspace
in order to properly take it it took me
like three days to like sit down because
i'm like i can't just like listen to
this
like it can't be back yeah i gotta like
really sit down and like like hone in on
this because i feel like it's such an
important album yes i don't want to
listen to it passively so i finally did
how's like how to find it man if i would
have listened to it passively i would
have been like
but it's amazing yeah yeah i haven't i
hadn't haven't had the chance to and i
really i want to do the same i want to
sit down and actually properly listen to
to it and i haven't been able to do that
yet so i will obviously at one point but
i know i i don't expect anything less
from kendrick what about just on the r b
side any um any fellow fellow ladies
that you're doing any and everyone okay
lonnie just dropped her album
yeah shout out to
um i listened to a lot of kiana leday
um like you said money just went i know
she just put out another single um who
else is i love snow
i even know snow's snow's album is
almost a year old now i think but i
listen to it like it came out yeah
snow's music is like very like uh
i just feel like it's like
it's like when you listen to an adele
album you're like i could hear this song
at a wedding in like 150 years like i
feel like snow's music is very in there
yeah she i i think you can like i could
me personally i can be in any mood like
whether i'm happy sad like energetic or
whatever and snow's music always just
makes me feel like i'm like at peace and
i love that i feel like you need like a
balance of like the turnip music
and um
yeah so snow i'm a big fan of snow
jasmine when you're when you're trying
to turn up what is the go-to
city girls city girls
shout out to the city girls yes i love
them they're amazing they are yeah
they're touring i think they're touring
with them oh jack
shout out to jack harlow he's he's doing
arenas he's killing it killing it yeah
i'm really happy for him
very surprised he didn't know ray j and
brandy were brother and sister i mean i
feel like everyone knows that i mean
we feel like everyone knows that because
we know it but like i don't think it was
like
like obviously i know that right but
like maybe he didn't grow up listening
to brandy and that's i feel like the
internet tries to like
they don't they definitely make sleep
yeah it's not a bit like it's not a big
yeah
maybe he didn't get around to like you
know tapping in with brandy like he said
he was like no one's ever told him that
in his life that's crazy um yeah shout
out to brandy uh she's a legend on this
project you also got lotto on the album
lotto has been um she's such a
sweetheart like she's one of my favorite
interviews i've done in a long time
she's hilarious yeah she's she's
actually like so personable but just so
like super down to earth she's really
funny like you just said yeah i met her
um
at a studio we were using the same
studio um just like randomly and she was
next door and i just went in and i was
like hi i'm a big fan and she was like
what are you like you know she was
really sweet to me and she says ciao
yeah she was really sweet to me and um i
had didn't say the song that she's on i
had that from the start of the recording
process that was one of the very first
ones that i recorded um and just never
had a second verse to it and i was just
like i think this is one that needs a
feature um and by the time we got around
to like figuring the features out i
already had roddy and i already had
lucky so i was like i want a female so
she's kind of a yeah different bag for
her to be in too i feel like yeah and i
think that's what's so interesting about
the song too because i think when you
look at like lma featuring lotto you're
like what what's that what in the world
does this sound like yeah um but she
killed it like literally she when she
sent me back the verse it was everything
i would have wanted her to say and i
didn't even have to like i don't like to
tell people i want you to say this like
you know i want you to do whatever you
do best because that's the reason i
would you know want you to collaborate
with me um and that was the greatest
part about that because the song
obviously spoke to her in the same way
it spoke to me and she killed her so i
was like
yeah she killed it um your writing
process break this down because i i
always see artists like i'm in the
studio obviously we're in my recording
studio right now so i always see like uh
you know i feel like nowadays when it
comes to rap people punch in their lines
you're obviously a prolific singer you
make prolific music thank you are you
writing ideas at home are you writing to
beats like how is your kind of like
process when it comes to like coming up
with ideas obviously you know you can
collaborate with other writers but in
terms of the stuff that you're like
putting your pen down on like like what
is that process for you i don't really
write at home like if i have an idea i
know like a lot of people will like
start writing something if they see
something or whatever i'm not really
that type of person i think i have to
um
hear
like a beat or hear some chords or
something like that in order for
inspiration to like come i like to work
off of whatever the beat or the chords
make me feel like
because like i don't wanna i don't wanna
have an idea and go to the studio and be
like this is what i need to make it
feels very forced when i do it i know
that works for some people um i rather
just catch the vibe to what is actually
going on in the studio at that time and
figure it out from there that's really
what we do most we kind of like whether
we're working to a beat or whether we're
starting from scratch if we're starting
from scratch it'll be like okay well
kind of how do you feel today and then
we'll go from there and then obviously
the chords will either be moody or
they'll be happy um
but i like to write in the studio what's
the song on the album if you had to pick
out one song that just came the easiest
to you where maybe you had something on
your chest you just had to get it off
and it just was like
it just happened so easy break my heart
was the quickest quickest one that we
wrote it literally took i don't even
think it took more than half an hour but
it's funny because that's like one of my
favorite songs on the album um it's like
it's it's
quite simple i like the the choruses if
i could choose who could if i had to
choose who could break my heart it would
be you which is a nuts concept
everyone's like girl what but it's kind
of it's kind of sweet to say no but like
i think people i think people are
misconstruing it like i'm not saying
like i'm going to choose you to break my
heart right if i had to choose like
worst case scenario if i had to choose
it will be you hmm is that so that's
like something you actually went through
right
um yeah yeah my this was my life in real
time my pandemic heartbreak
yeah i guess you could say that how do
you get over heartbreak in the pandemic
because it's a very you know it was a
pretty wild i mean i don't know if you
were in la a lot of the time i spent
quite a bit in leia because l.a [ __ ] got
kind of crazy out here yeah in terms of
like thinking about that like the first
like few months it felt like
we were in a movie in gothemia like yeah
i think to be fair i like
i wouldn't say it was like a super super
bad like it was heartbreak yes but it
wasn't like a super super bad breakup or
anything it wasn't ugly yeah it wasn't
ugly um so it wasn't as hard as it
probably seems um and i have great
friends and great family so i think
that's important like even though
they're not physically around during the
pandemic but like facetime makes you
feel very a lot closer obviously um and
yeah i don't really i don't really have
like a step to step how i did it i just
kind of took it kind of dealt with it
yeah so it wasn't it wasn't anything
crazy like you didn't get cheated on
anything no no no no no no no no the
cheating [ __ ] is like the hardest thing
to get over i've gotten cheated on in my
life before and it is very um yeah it's
it's bad do you feel like i had this
conversation with my friend the other
day do you feel like you could stay with
someone after they cheat like do you
think that the relationship is is
solvable almost um
[Music]
in my case you personally yeah i tried
it out yeah it didn't work but we have
there was a kid involved okay um but it
definitely
since i lived through that i would say
probably not
i would say like once that trust is
probably violated like it's just hard
it's hard it's probably hard to go it's
just yeah i think it's harder and i
think like uh i guess it i mean listen
circumstances are
you know they change like i guess case
the case but i would say like
you know it just depends i guess it
depends on what happened how toxic the
situation is i hate toxic situations we
don't want any any toxic situations over
here yeah yeah so i think like yeah if
it's like something like i don't know i
was a part of a pretty terrible
relationship so um you know it was
something that like i just tried to make
work over and over for my kid's sake and
the best thing i ever did was just like
you know what i mean
so now i have my son who i have custody
of you know i mean so shout out to
myself it's amazing yeah shout out to
you um but yeah it was definitely yeah i
would say like if you get cheated on i
mean look everyone's different i i guess
like if the circumstances are
crazy then yeah you should probably
bounce
you should probably move on what about
you have you ever taken someone back
after cheating i've
i haven't been cheated onto my knowledge
oh well that's good that's good we'll
shout out to you yeah you're [ __ ]
lucky
i know that's not the case in most
people's um most people's
life yeah we just had a topic on the
radio where someone called in and they
found out that their husband cheated
like 10 years prior
and like
he pretty much admitted to it i don't
know but never cheated again after that
right so she found out that like 10
years prior yeah
that he had cheated and she was like
what should what should i do what would
you do if let's say you're in a
relationship hypothetically you're with
a guy for seven or eight years and you
found out in the first year he cheated
it but you found out he hasn't cheated
since
would you would you kind of be like like
that's kind of a weird situation right
it's a 50 50 because it's like
obviously i understand why he didn't
tell her
but it's also like well you've kind of
lied to me for all these years so
how you're pretty comfortable with lying
to me yeah so how can i actually even
prove that you've never done it again
one but two
yeah i don't know i don't i don't know
if i could i could i would much rather
you tell me when it happened right away
and let me deal with it and figure out
whether i want to stay with you or not
um and then we go from there as opposed
like but did she find out like she saw
something and she asked him and then he
admitted it or he came out and was like
he admitted it
like he came up to her and said ten
years ago i cheated yeah i don't know
it's an interesting predicament but like
you said what works for one doesn't work
for the other like it's very
circumstantial it depends on the case so
um i hope i hope for her sake she finds
happiness wherever it is what is uh your
go-to binge watch tv shows lma oh
euphoria
god loves you love you for oh my god i'm
obsessed um but i really don't watch
that much tv to be honest i think
uh somebody was just telling me i need
to watch what's the show called
i can't even remember um i think
euphoria was probably the last thing
i've been yeah was your high school like
even 10 like euphoria
not that i know of either i was
completely out the loop and was like not
part of the cool kids or uh yeah no it
wasn't but i do understand
how it's changed i graduated high school
10 years ago social media i think has
really like uh
just changed like i let my my son 16 and
i let him watch you for you and you know
he's a good kid so i was just like yeah
dude but
that [ __ ] better not be going on at your
school right but he said that he's like
no there's kids who [ __ ] will come to
school super high he was like there's
kids that sell pills like i'm like damn
yeah i think the most that happened when
i was in high school was like weed i
remember one time
my
some of my friends uh came to school
drunk but like it was such a one-off
that like they
made it so hot like they made it so big
that they were drunk that they got found
out so which this is how you know you
don't do this on a regular basis right
right yeah because you got caught yeah
you got caught but they were just doing
the most um but that was probably the
only time
i remember that other than people like
who would smoke after school i guess but
yeah she's uh incredible jesus amazing
it's actually wild amazing yeah yeah she
should get all the awards for that show
like her acting at that show is amazing
yeah so just just euphoria yeah that's
all i can think of right now i really
don't what about any classics like you
ever watch friends or anything or uh
my wife and kids my wife and kids watch
my wife i love my wife and kids i don't
even know i've heard of the show which
guy's in it who's in it are you are you
being are you actually being serious let
me just look up who's in here listen
there's so many tasha campbell
is it like damon damon williams yeah
it's a damon away show no which one i i
get confused by all of them damon wayans
uh
uh it's
parker mckenna when she was really
little i remember the show yes yeah i
never watched it though oh my god how
can you not i don't know
i'm not really into like besides like if
i'm like going super old i loved like
martin yeah seinfeld hanging with mr
cooper
but like
kind of the newer uh sitcoms i just kind
of just didn't tap into you know what i
can always bring what binge watch and
i'll never get tired of that's a raven
that's so ravency i'm totally i mean i
know who i know the show yeah i know who
shout out to her raven simone but i
never watched it that's so raven was
like almost like my
like i thought i was raving my kid would
watch the suite life with zach and cody
yeah i watched that so that was like
you know
like disney disney channel era so like
lizzie mcguire
i'm obviously older than you just a
little bit but it's okay it's okay yeah
my wife and kids i i could always be
shout out to damon wayans yes have you
ever seen major payne with damon wayans
i haven't you gotta watch that movie i
was gonna say it's a movie yeah it's a
movie yeah yeah shout out today yo we
got to stop the interview real quick
shout out to our presenting sponsor odd
socks baby hey man listen all i keep on
my ass is odd socks draws all i keep in
my feet socks you know why because they
are the most comfortable socks in the
world and i'm not just saying this
because they promote the podcast
i'm telling you the socks are crazy uh
they got all the licenses look they got
halloween socks they have back to the
future socks
they got [ __ ] twizzler socks
old dirty bastard socks r.i.p to odb all
right they also got their draws if you
want to wear some underwear with pizza
on them whatever you need but my
favorite are the odd socks basics baby
these are just the plain boys these to
me are the most comfortable socks in the
world all right
so trust me when i say go to
oddssoxofficial.com
thank me later when you go to check out
buying the most comfortable socks in the
world
get some wwe socks too i just saw a
sneak peek of the new wwe line and
they're [ __ ] insane
in [ __ ] sane
uh go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word together bootleg kev
we should talk to them about shortening
that bootleg kev is the promo code you
will get 20 off at checkout one more
time go to oddssocksofficial.com save 20
off using that promo code bootleg kev
let's get back to the interview um yo
it's crazy too because like i feel like
um i was just we just had junior choi up
here who's obviously from the uk and
we're kind of talking about how like
you know for so long i feel like um
obviously your genre music is
is
very receptive in the states but for so
long i feel like um
you know it was like a little harder for
uk artists to kind of break over here
kind of doing uk [ __ ] but you know i
feel like you know um
drill is kind of changing the drill and
i don't think a lot of people understand
that like obviously drill started in
chicago but like the uk drill scene is
what inspired the brooklyn drill scene
and um did i just feel like right now in
the states like the uk's got its
fingerprints on everything like i think
so yeah i mean a lot of stuff you know
what i mean like and i think like i
don't know what happened but you know
obviously like yourself
ed sheeran adele you know you guys are
superstars but in terms of just like you
know i guess
because i feel like i know afrobeat is
you know a lot of that's but i feel like
i feel like that
popped off in the uk first and then
yeah afrobeat so joe you're talking
about afrobeats yeah that's been a thing
in the uk forever yeah forever literally
um
i think so like you said social media
makes things a lot more accessible and
makes people like as crazy as it is
because there's a lot of stuff on there
that we really don't need to take of
course of course it's also great in
terms of just like being able to uh
reach people but or things being able to
reach you that you would have never
known if you were just i don't know in
the middle of america somewhere randomly
and you don't really travel or something
right um so yeah i think social media
plays a big a big role in that also yo
it's crazy since your last album came
out tick tock has been a it's became a
thing tick tock is wild i don't feel
like you i mean listen there's no music
for tick-tock but i don't feel like
you're like a you know a tick-tock
artist not really at all right but like
it is it is the things that go viral on
tick-tock there's no uh explanation
behind them it just happens but like
is the label like in your head about
tick tock now oh lord because it's i can
only imagine it's extremely obnoxious
because i can't stand tick-tock is so
it's such a [ __ ] headache
even for me i don't have it i don't have
tick-tock on my phone i have a tick-tock
i don't run it um but it's very it's
funny to me because i just saw something
where i think it was charlie xcx um
and she was like this is my eighth tick
tock that my label are trying to force
me to do blah blah she was joking but
like i felt her so much because it but
like i understand it obviously a label
are trying to make their money of course
that's where the attention's at yeah
that's what where the attention is right
now and i'm sure in a couple years it
will be something else and the kids love
tik tok and that's just such a
ridiculous platform yeah i don't i've
never personally gotten into it i don't
think there's anything wrong with it
obviously but it's just thank god
because you'd be on your phone just
scrolling because that out they got the
best algorithm in the world on tick tock
yeah they got it figured out speaking of
algorithm
algorithm just in general right now i
feel like on social media is just like
really weird super i'm trying to
understand what's going on yeah it's uh
i don't i don't know
twitter is a wild place right now
twitter's always been the wild wild west
though it is
yeah you know what the what i hate about
twitter
is if someone you know is a creep and
they like some nasty [ __ ] on twitter you
see it
it pops up on your feed and it says so
and so like this and i'm like
what the [ __ ] i didn't want to see this
yeah no i think i think twitter's wit a
weird place because
i think
twitter gives people a reason to think
that their opinion is fact
yeah i think that's what's wrong and
don't get me wrong twitter is hilarious
there's parts of twitter that is just
like we'll have you really really dying
but
any anybody
types anything and it can go viral
especially now and then they think that
like their opinion yeah they think that
they're they're experts on stuff they're
super educated about something and it's
like bro
your opinion isn't fact it can be
obviously people agree with it yes but
now now we've got people walking around
thinking that they like know everything
and it's just like
are you a fan of elon musk trying to buy
twitter and fix it up uh i don't really
have an opinion on it yeah to be honest
i don't know enough about him
do you have a tesla i don't know no not
yet
with these gas prices you might need to
get listen it's crazy i don't understand
what not even just gas prices though but
just like like inflation in general is
just like it's actually wild right now i
went to buy hamburger meat and i was
like how much it was like [ __ ] 19
dollars what it was crazy yeah yeah
inflation um there's a baby
formula shortages i heard about that
yeah the gas prices are crazy
shit's wild right now
still kind of in a pandemic
did you buy like are you a homeowner if
you don't mind me asking yeah so you got
to buy a house you probably got a good
interest rate then uh
yeah i did because right now the
interest rates were yeah no it was it
was a little while ago oh okay okay oh
then you're you're rich
you're up you're super up i mean you're
rich anyway but like you're up on the
house for sure i mean i guess for sure
yeah i just bought my first house so
well not my first house ever but my
first house in l.a congrats it was
expensive
i think and honestly and i'm i've lived
now in three major cities i live
obviously i'm from london i've lived in
new york i live in l.a um i like to like
go back and forth but
i'm so i'm i'm so used to the city that
like if i was to go down south or and i
understand it's like so much cheaper
down there and then you can get a lot
more for your money but like i just have
to i don't think i can function in
somewhere that's not like a city
right like a major city right um and
they're always expensive like which out
of those three places
obviously london is home
but just in terms of livability
what do you like the most new york
london or la i'd probably say here yeah
i'll tell you this i go to new york and
i understand why everyone's there is
like an [ __ ] loki you know what i
mean it's a very like
imagine like every everybody's just
walking to work and you're next to them
and then you have to take the train with
everyone london's quite similar
everyone's in a rush
london's past like when like you know
you always hear like in new york if you
get mugged like everyone just keeps it
moving and i'm like i went and i was
like dude i get it now you see some of
the stuff that happens like in in the
subway in new york like if you like on
twitter i'll just see the wildest stuff
that happens and it's just like people
just like if you're on the train right
and someone like starts breaking out
dancing or just doing random stuff
obviously for social media but like new
yorkers are not even affected by they
mind their [ __ ] business
you would think nothing's going on new
york is like the king of minding your
business it is the capital of minding
your [ __ ] business yeah you go to new
york people don't give a [ __ ] they are
trying to get home they're trying to get
to work i get it though yeah i can't
understand it i completely understand it
and i think london's similar it's not i
don't think it's as like
it's definitely as fast paced i would
say but i think people are a little more
uh what's the right word
um hospitable yeah like if something's
happening i think someone will at least
try and help or whatever else do you
feel like london gets a bad rap on food
because anytime i ever hear about uk
food it everyone says it's super bland
and it's uh yeah but i understand why i
think you have to obviously know where
to go yes i think that's anywhere
um and i think that
a lot of the places even in any city
actually that i've been in a lot of the
good food is not obviously in the
touristy parts um that's like the i tell
people to get off yelp yeah that's the
gene but that's the generic food yeah
like you know they're trying to appease
a lot of different people because this
is a tourist area you have to go to like
the hood or go to like the real cultured
places in order to get good food i think
that's most places that i've been to be
fair last thing break down just um the
name of your album hot on my screen
heart on my sleeve yeah um i mean it's
pretty much what what it says i think i
wear my harm not even i think i know i
would i know you do yeah just in general
yeah it was a great listen a great album
thank you um
i'm assuming there's videos already shot
that are coming soon tour come in yeah
we're planning it right now so
definitely are you excited to get back
on the road it's my favorite part of all
of this touring yes going and seeing the
people singing along to your songs is
there like anything that feels better
than that when you're performing a song
and you got you know all these people
singing word for word it's literally
unmatched it's the best feeling ever i
can only imagine yeah well element i
appreciate you coming through thank you
thank you for having me go get the album
yes
and go watch my wife and kids